BIDEN GE ARGUED THAT UM O STOP
HON.EENLEME CN PRESIDENT  PAINT.
HENOWS T HE
TRIES N  ARIT.  CITYPORTLAND, W
THENTI CABLAZE TIME. MTE TIMES P
IR LAND, NONSENSE.TH FE TOLHECK
THE CITY IS NZEE ISOLATED PF FIS
HADEDRE ENGINE T>>PORTND YE FOR
OFING THIS CURSE.
NONSENSE
NONSSEHADDLE TO AOSING AND PEND
YOU WOULD THINK PORTLAND  YRS BL
ALONE DECADESS T PRESIDENT
CLISTEN LIES ABOUT HIS R ON
>> SINCE THEEGTIONLE,"
UC MORE THAN1,000
ARRDER
SA
CITIES WEETY. 33HAT'S
DECD
THERE ACC TO DATA OBTAID T
THEORDED 1S THIS YEA PUTTING IT
ON TRA BHE32 HOMICIDES
OPERA WANNOUNCED IUL A
AI C HEACTS N THET
>> I'LLOINT TOUGH ON
STIFFER PENAGE TERMS FOR ALICE
GREAT CRIMES.
WHEN YOUENFO RD
LL NEED ORDER
WE ORDER.WH AM PRESIDENTLL LAB
EPFE PSI H A
DING IS
PP WATCH.KI AND CRICANSID VIOLEE
IC OF F
TICIAN THAT IS OUR
NATION AND  WHEN THE RTEOMYO TE
>>GS
>>SE ARE PEOPLE NOWNG S L.
>> TOUR
Y DON'TT THAT
JUNTDBLUSE. OU
AFRAIDEC
MIBE TOR TOIOLENCSM TO SCAREOTPT
REACTION TON
TOE
VYBO
PROTESTING.SEGOTESTING.
OTESTING.S.
HO IT INSDEMNINRU
IT.
BOUTRTLANDR WAS
SHOTND T PART A C
IN DOWNTOWN PR
AINTING TO A WITNE MARBLES
OM
>> YOU WUSRI SAYING HE DIDFARIF
AL VIETE AND
DID NOT MENTION YERALSO IN
FIRING PAINT BALL AT
LEE PEPPER SPRAY.
AKE THISHAHAT YOU SUPPORTER?
>> I UND NUMBEOPRTERS
PEACEFULPRNT
NOT -- P
>> THAT INORAY PSGHNG SUPPORTER
WOUNDED A
>> THAT N INTERESTING
TU
YOU SAWHE SAME TAPE SAS TRYING U
HEBE
H
WOULKILLED
IT I ICE THAT  INDLYSOMERA
PEOPLE FROM T C NT OF THE UD ST.
BUT EVEN IF PEO IN THE
STREETS, LAW,OTGOT EEN
POLICE THEM AND TTH OF
THENITEST SEES  HE IMMED TORETRT
OM THATSE THE HIM, WES C O
THWASN'T SELF
DEFENSE.
CALLED HIM OUTSHOOTING.T'S TY S
HOMICIDE CHARGES.
AND IN NEW YORK  THEIC IS WAROT
SHOOTER DIDA. P LASWOULD WANT
IT LAW BROTHERS ANDROH L
OWDER KEG ANDHRUS
TI LEADER
PRESIDENT OT H IS ARGUINGT HE T
BUT CLEARLYSER.
HE SAYS T
NT VE
HE IS AST BLA
HE'S JUST F W
TG ME NOW IS CNNTAYLOR,
OFEPARTMENT OFECURIT
TRUMMINIRA SUPPORTING
JOE BIDEN IN NOV
WHEN W , IS ITETHINGLD EMBNEO
TO TEGASTTHINK TT
PEOPLE WILMART WON'T DO WNNA.
I WORRY ATHI LIESTUT HIJA BPLE
THE SCENE S
RHETOR AND ABILI  FUREN HAD THEL
SAY FROM NHIIS KEG. LIKENED ITAH
HE LEGITIMATE HEIR TO A
CO ADNT DOE'T
THIS IS RHETOSEEN A LFIALNDECAU